um thank you so much for being on the
program it's great to talk to you today
so you've just been appointed uh by the
chancellor onto his economics advisory
panel I'm interested to know like given
the kind of economic landscape we're in
what would be your like number one piece
of advice to politicians
hi Sophie I think um you can't look much
further than growth right now
we haven't got any
just at the moment it's been anemic now
for the better part of 15 years in
accounting
that makes all choices difficult it
feels to me like growth has become
almost a bit of a dirty word after the
Liz truss mini Mega budget
how do you get growth in a responsible
way yeah well I think the key word there
is is responsible
and sustainable
and inclusive
so I think you know what went wrong last
year with the dash for growth is it
wasn't seen as being a sustainable plan
for growth so what would that look like
then well I think ultimately this is
about expanding
how we produce as a country rather than
what we consume as a country
it's about more people being in the
workforce
and it's about those people producing
more that's the way we grow our capacity
to produce as a country well sometimes
called the supply side of the economy
stimulating spending is dead easy but
ultimately it's what we produce that
determines long-term growth and is there
any sort of specific policies that you
point to that could be helpful yeah so
think of it in two bits
so roughly speaking economics dead
simple
you can expand the economy either by
growing the workforce
or by making that Workforce more
productive okay so on the first what can
we do to expand our Workforce bearing in
mind Sophie our Workforce has contracted
over the past couple of years by about
half a million people
that's why we've got one million
unfilled vacancies that's why every
sector and every region is screaming
blue murder about an absence of Staff
what could we do to expand the numbers
of people available and in work
well immigration is one safety valve
ruled out by both parties wrong
probably
I think
um given the scale
and spread of skill shortages
for
not operating a little bit to alleviate
those through skilled controlled migrant
labor is a mistake inflation is
obviously a huge concern alongside race
and something that all of our viewers
can be feeling yeah what's your I mean
we've seen the figures out obviously uh
still above 10 percent
how difficult to think the Outlook is
for inflation or is it going to get
better
so it's been a very very difficult 18
months let's be absolutely clear we've
got inflation still in double digits
um and growth pretty much at zero that's
the wrong place on both fronts
the bad news and it is bad news because
we've seen the biggest squeeze on
household budgets over the past 18
months as we've seen since the 50s
actually
very difficult position
the good news is I think from here
from around the second half of the Year
things will begin to improve gradually
but they will begin to improve why do I
say that the world's getting a bit
better not loads better but a bit better
it's getting its mojo back and that will
help us help us sell more of our stuff
overseas the big cause of that squeeze
on living standards has been high
inflation as you mentioned
that will begin
to head south pretty soon probably
starting next month actually and at a
rate of knots because the biggest single
reason why it's picked up to 10 plus is
because of high energy prices and they
have now come off at a real rate of not
over the course of the past six months
and that will start to show up
headline rates of inflation starting
pretty soon
and you fast forward six months
I think the headline inflation rate will
not be double digits it might be three
four or five so we should see next
Target then to halve inflation that
looks pretty safe pretty much nailed on
a lot of what I'm hearing from the
government is look we have to have pay
restraint because that fuels inflation
so increasing pay as obviously lots of
people in the public sector want to see
is a bad thing for the economy what do
you make of that well there's a question
of balance there it's certainly true
that
um one of the biggest single sources of
inflection is how much workers are paid
that's just a matter of the cost
arithmetic facing businesses
um and a degree of moderation whether in
the setting of wages but also in the
setting of prices by businesses
is necessary right now given that a
country given that as a country we are
somewhat poorer basically the price of
stuff that we buy from overseas has gone
up a lot
energy and food and that means as a
country we are somewhat poorer
the pain of that has been felt by
workers through pay and to an extent
by businesses in the form of reduced
profits and higher higher costs
nonetheless there is no question that
the way we grow as a country is by
having people's pay packets Rising
not falling over time and that I hope
and expect we'll see second half of the
year I'm interested to talk to you about
interest rates and mortgages as well
obviously you used to work at the bank
of England
How concerned are you about what is
happening when it comes to interest
rates how high do you think they might
go
yeah so we've seen them rise from almost
nothing um
to now what for the quarter percent
which is a pretty chunky rise in a
relatively short space of time and a
surprise to lots of people
um
um the big question is what happens next
I mean truth be told
even the rice so far Sophie has not been
felt
in most people's mortgage payments so
far many wrong fixed rates and those
fixed rates haven't reset yet
because the effects of the tightening
scene so far
haven't fully been felt and that would
personally had been back in my old job
at the bank of England set interest
rates which was my previous life for
seven years
that would give me cause for pause
I think hang on the economy is still an
unsteady legs right now
much the timing that's already happened
hasn't yet hit people's bank accounts
perhaps Now's the Time to press the
pause button and see what happens
because because of people's pain in the
mortgage rates and because it's going to
become difficult in this year Well
having faced a cost of living squeeze if
you're Rising the cost of borrowing as
well as the cost of living that
compounds the agony yeah I'm not sure
right now whether businesses or
households are ready for the double
whammy of those two things
personally I'd be thinking hard about
pausing equally I think it's likely the
bank will feel the need to keep on
Rising further and financial markets
feel the same because those price
pressures and those wage pressures
remain well above the bank's two percent
Target I want to talk to you about
leveling up as well at your chair the
leveling up advisory Council
it's one of those phrases that it's so
common we hear all the time we had a
whole election campaign around it and
both sides of the house are using it
what do you think leveling up actually
means what is that about yeah well for
me it's it's um someone who grew up in a
pool place in the north uh it's about
unlocking the potential what you've got
uh in Yorkshire just north of Leeds I
was born in Sunderland a place that
isn't doing well hasn't been doing well
for 70 years
so I know what leveling up feels like
um and I know what success looks like
you know in in my prayer life at the
bank of England I said most of my time
walking around the country
seeing the economy firsthand
place is doing well of which there are
many right now and places surfing far
less well so it's definitely an
achievable goal it's also a desirable
one this is about unlocking the
potential in people and in places which
is very very considerable what are the
ingredients for success is probably your
next question
somewhere seeing I think
you know the solution doesn't lie in
Whitehall hands it doesn't lie in
central government's hands it must lie
in local hands
this will only happen locally if it's
led by local people so the Devolution
agenda
the proliferation of mares I think is
really really important and on that you
know both parties are now leaning
heavily in to giving more power back to
the people it's interesting to talk
about your own sort of Journey from
Sunderland to some of the wealthiest
individuals and companies and areas of
the United Kingdom and for many people
they would say that to enable that
journey to happen for more people
you need to look at education yeah do
you think politicians are taking
education as serious as they should no I
don't I think we we are not having a
conversation about education and
learning
and we need to we know that without that
we are pushing money and water uphill
uh so absolutely we need to build out
the skill based from the earliest of
yours through to a lifelong basis
to create you know we are chronically
short of people and skills in this
country more than 10 million people in
the workforce do not have their skills
they need for the workplace
half of all school kids half of all
school kids leave school loathing
learning rather than loving it that is
the worst endowment possible the one
thing you really want above all else for
our education system to do
is to embed a love of learning because
if you love it you'll keep on doing it
what's your idea about maths to 18 is
that good idea so we are a new an
enumerate relation and the prominence is
absolutely right about that I'm the vice
chair of national numeracy would expect
me to say it's a real positive it is a
real positive
but one it's not about mathematics as
currently taught this is about basic
number skills can I add up can I
subtract can I make
numbers for real and helping me live my
life pay for my mortgage pay for my
grocery bill
but it's also about other things
you know it's not just about stem
science technology engineering and maths
it's also about putting the a into stem
and making it steam out is to say arts
and humanities
what will protect us
from the rise of the machine from the
rise of AI is our creative capacity as
human beings and yeah that's often the
first thing to become in budgets it has
been we've seen the
the dwindling budgets for arts and
humanities the dwindling number of
people young people taking arts and
humanities
and that's a mistake that's a big
mistake for the jobs and skills of
tomorrow